خارج مكتب رئاسه الوزراء لكنه داخل قلب
العواصف جونسون يغادر البرلمان البريطاني
رئيس الوزراء الاسبق يتخذ القرار على
خلفيه التحقيق البرلماني حول فضيحه بارتي
التي لا تزال تحاصر جونسون رغم نهايه
الجائحه فبورص تلاحقه اتهامات خرق القيود
الصحيه باستضافه مقر التينكس حفلات في عز
ازمه جائحه كورونا البالغ من العمر 58
عاما اكد ان قراره يدخل حيز التنفيذ فورا
ما يعني بالضروره اجراء انتخابات فرعيه
ستشكل عبئا وضغطا سياسيين مضاعفين على
رئيس الوزراء الحالي ريشيسوناك التحقيق
يسعى لتحديد ما اذا كان جونسون قد ضلل
البرلمان في قضيه بارتيجات اجراء تقوده
لجنه الامتيازات البرلمانيه التي باتت
قريبه من انهاء عملها اذ قدمت استنتاجاتها
الى الزعيم السابق حسب الصحافه البريطانيه
جونسون لجنه بما سماه تحيزا فاضحا انا
حزين جدا لمغادره البرلمان على الاقل في
الوقت الحالي لكن قبل كل شيء الشعور
بالاستياء لانني اجبرت على المغادره
بطريقه غير ديمقراطيه بيان جونسون اتهم
اللجنه ايضا باصدار تقرير لم ينشر بعد
يتضمن مغالطات وتحيزا
التطورات تاتي بعد عام على اقصائهم من
تندونس بايادي غالبيه حزبه المحافظين اثر
ثلاث سنوات عجاف في السلطه تزامنت مع فتره
الجائحه وما صاحب ذلك من سلسله فضائح
اطاحت براسه في النهايه من الحكومه
والبرلمان بلال البجدين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات